on va en parler avec notre invité le
philosophe et politologue ukrainien
volody Mira hier molenko bonjour à vous
vous êtes aussi rédacteur en chef
d'Ukraine world.org professeur à
l'université moïla Academy à Kiev déjà à
quoi sert selon vous l'adoption de cette
nouvelle doctrine diplomatique
je ne sais pas parce que si la Russie
est un état d'ouvroy bien sûr les
doctrines sont importantes parce que
c'est la base de telle ou telle
politique la Russie est gouverné par un
tyran donc je sais pas si ils utilisent
des doctrines des documents comme ça
mais ce qui était intéressant dans ce
doctrine c'est que
la Russie est définie comme État
civilisation donc c'est vraiment
l'idéologie de ces doctrine c'est le
racisme ou le néo-résisme à la dougine
et quelque chose comme ça donc ils
essaient les Russes ils essaient de se
détacher de l'Occident de se détacher de
l'Europe
l'une des justifications de la Russie
pour cette guerre en Ukraine c'était
justement de combattre cette expansion
de l'OTAN j'en parlais à l'instant on
voit bien que au contraire cette guerre
elle a provoqué accéléré la demande
d'adhésion de la Suède et de la Finlande
la Finlande qui rejoint le temps demain
donc l'OTAN le territoire de l'OTAN sera
contigu cette fois-ci à la Russie qui
prévient qu'elle va militariser cette
frontière est-ce que selon vous Vladimir
Poutine a cherché cette confrontation se
figer ainsi deux blocs autant et réussi
ou est-ce que il a été pris à son propre
jeu est-ce que c'était volontaire
finalement c'est un grand stratège qu'on
le sait Vladimir Poutine donc
l'ironie de cette situation c'est que il
atteint des objectifs qui sont
contraires à ces objectifs donc il a dit
bah voilà il faut il faut il faut
terminer l'élargissement de l'OTAN qu'il
attend maintenant c'est l'élargissement
de l'OTAN il a dit que il fallait il a
condamné le temps pour je sais pas pour
faire la guerre contre la Russie ça n'a
jamais arrivé mais maintenant on voit
quand même plus de d'armement en Ukraine
le soutien de l'OTAN de l'Ukraine etc
donc il faut dire je pense que la
politique de Poutine en fait c'est le
contraire des intérêts géopolitiques de
la Russie il faut le dire
les citoyens russes doivent le
comprendre tout ce que est logique tout
ce qui est rationnel de point de vue
géopolitique économique etc Poutine fait
le contraire on a vu que justement il y
avait une vraie guerre de l'information
à côté de cette guerre sur le terrain en
Ukraine avec aujourd'hui la mort de ce
blogueur qui était un des relais de
l'ultra-nationalisme
russe quelle est la fonction en fait
dans le dispositif de guerre de la
Russie de
votre blogueur de ces intervenants sur
les réseaux sociaux de ces médias pro
russe donc c'est difficile de le nommer
blogueur mais monsieur total ce qui est
parce que c'est un criminel c'est
quelqu'un qui était été emprison en 2014
en Ukraine je pense que c'est à orlifa
donc à l'est de l'Ukraine ensuite il est
participé dans la guerre comme
combattant de du côté des forces pro
russe et là maintenant c'est quand même
logique que lui il est proche de
prigogène qui est aussi le patron de
Wagner qui qui assemble des criminels
surtout chez Wagner surtout dans cette
bataille autour de Barmont etc on va
rappeler que tout de même pour ceux qui
ne suivent pas l'actualité comme vous
que Wagner a recruté aussi parmi des
détenus ah bien sûr parce que sinon
qu'ils peuvent qu'ils peuvent recruter
c'est c'est ça leur base principale
alors tata ce que c'est c'est quelqu'un
de ce type et lui oui il s'est nommé VO
incorre c'est-à-dire à correspondant de
guerre mais c'est pas du tout des
correspondants de guerre c'est pas du
tout des journalistes donc il s'agit il
s'agit des anciens criminels qui sont
devenus des combattants ou des
instruments de cette guerre de la Russie
qui sont devenus ensuite les instruments
de la guerre d'information et c'est vrai
que c'est par la moyenne de de chaîne de
télégramme télégramme c'est un réseau
sociaux qui est très très utilisé
maintenant par la propagande russe que
ils essaient de voilà les Russes ils
essaient essayer de promouvoir leur
message comme voilà la guerre va
continuer que ils vont remporter contre
l'Ukraine etc
c'est la deuxième fois que Wagner
revendique une victoire sur place que
l'état-major russe ne confirme pas
puisque aujourd'hui le point de
l'état-major russe ne confirme pas que
Wagner contrôle la mairie de barmouth
qu'est-ce qui se passe exactement entre
entre Wagner dont le patron a gagné
Prigogine ne s'est pas privé de de
critiquer le Kremlin de façon assez
acerbe dernièrement est-ce que la Russie
les autorités russes ne laissent pas
aussi Wagner sans liser à barmouth
s'épuiser à barthout
je pense que vous avez raison de l'autre
côté barmut c'est une ville symbolique
c'est une ville très importante bien sûr
mais c'est une ville dont la bataille
est depuis je pense que moi de juillet
au mois de août et juste pour vous
rappeler à votre public ce n'est pas un
grandit c'est pas une ville d'un million
d'habitants c'est une ville de qui était
avant la guerre sur 60000 habitants
de grande de grande intérêts stratégique
absolument absolument c'est ça que qui
nous donne la qui nous donne qui nous
donne à comprendre que cette guerre que
même la Russie absolument sans sens il
est absurde et il y a pour les Russes
c'est très symboliquement important
parce qu'ils veulent récupérer ou
occuper les restes de la région de
donnéesk mais il y a il y a beaucoup
d'autres
îles à la région de données c'est comme
cela vient comme kamatos qu'on visite
très très souvent
on parlait dernièrement d'une volonté de
contre-offensive
ukrainienne d'épuiser justement les
forces russes à barmouth pour mener
cette contre-offensive est-ce que
l'Ukraine aussi s'épuise après plus d'un
an de guerre est-ce que aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine a besoin
de rassembler ses forces ou peu lancer
la contre-offensive très prochainement
mais faut comprendre que les forces pour
la contrainte et les forces qui sont à
barmoud abdivk
à côté de Liman on visite très souvent
ces villes là ce sont des forces
différentes c'est à dire que les forces
qui se préparent à la contre-offensive
sont des forces différentes qui ce qui
s'entraînent aussi dans les dans
l'Europe de l'Ouest en Amérique etc donc
pour se préparer à cette contrainte
offensive la morale des Ukrainiens ça
reste très très forte
sauf que bien sûr
notre vie est très difficile la vie des
soldats sur le front est très difficile
on perd beaucoup de gens
et bien sûr c'est très tragique c'est
pas la géopolitique c'est pas le jeu
d'échec pour nous le facebook maintenant
c'est que des que des
que des informations sur les morts y
compris les morts de de
nos amis de nos proches
mais voilà il y a il y a cette volonté
de de mener la contre-offensive et
effectivement et la question
d'épuisement je pense que c'est très
important parce que parfois j'attends ok
mais les Russes veulent épuiser les
Ukrainiens c'est leur stratégie oui mais
je pense que il faut aussi penser à
l'inverse c'est les Russes s'épuisent
aussi s'épuisent de façon beaucoup plus
grave parce qu'il perde beaucoup plus
d'hommes que les Ukrainiens je pense que
la proportion est trois ou quatre pour
un et c'est important de de comprendre
que les Ukrainiens croivent à la
victoire il nous donne beaucoup de
sacrifices pour la victoire mais c'est
quand même dur merci beaucoup pour le
dîner guillermolenco d'avoir été
l'invité de France 24 ce soir merci